شهران اذا يفصلان المملكه المتحده
البريطانيه عن حفل تتويج الملك تشارلز بدا
باعداد الطقوس والخطوات الاولى من القدس
قصر الملكي استقبل شحنه من الزيت المقدس
الذي يستخدم في مراسم تتويج الملك الجديد
كانت كنيسه القيامه في مدينه القدس شهدت
عمليه مباركه الزيت الذي سيمسح به ملك
بريطانيا اثناء حفل تتويجه في شهر مايو
المقبل الزيت المقدس يتم استخراجه من
الزيتون المقطوف من مدينه القدس القديمه
من بساتين دير القديسه مريم المجدليه ودير
الصعود على جبل الزيتون والتي تحمل قدسيه
لدى المسيحيين تاريخ مراسم الدهن والعاده
الملكيه عبر الاجيال مع علاء سرحان
اذا حفل تتويج ملوك المملكه المتحده يكون
احتفالا كبيرا وفخما يتم عقده مع تقاليد
تعود الى قرون مضت ففي سن 25 خضعت الملكه
اليزابيث لطقوس خاصه بالدهن باستخدام زيوت
عطريه سيتم عقد حدث مماثل الان للملك
تشارلز الثالث عند موعد تتويجه بحسب بي بي
سي تشمل الطقوس القديمه للدهن استخدام
الزيوت التي يتم حفظها في علبه قديمه
مملوءه بالخلطات العطريه في زجاجه على
الرغم من اخفاء طقوس الدهن عن الجمهور فان
اهميه مسح الملك وجعله يشم رائحه الزيت
العطري هو رمز للامنيات بالنسبه لهم
ليعيشوا حياه طويله وصحيه وسعيده وهذا
ملزم بواجبهم تجاه التاج والبلد وفقا
للمؤرخين الملكيين يعود تاريخ مراسم الدهن
الى القرون القديمه عندما كانت هذه الزيوت
تعتبر رمزا لقوه الملك وذكر المؤرخون
الملكيون حب الملكه اليزابيث للعطور
والزيوت العطريه المستخلصه من حديقتها
باستخدام الزهور والاعشاب النادره التي
تستخدم طبيا وترفيهيا
[موسيقى]
احنا بدنا نوجه تحيه لخالد القاسم اللي هو
اول مراسل
ظهر بتقرير على صباح العربيه
عشرين سنه يسعد صباحك يا خالد انضم الينا
اذا من رام الله خالد القاسم يسعدها الله
يا خالد اهلا بك
ترد على نادين
الله يسعد صباحكم نديم وسهام وصباح
العربيه دائما يكون متالق مش بعد 20 سنه
بعد 200 سنه يا رب يكون متالق فيكم وفي كل
طاقم العمل يا رب يسعدك يا خالد خالد
تتويج الملك البريطاني يتم بجلب زيت خصيصا
من القدس وهي عاده ملكيه متوارثه عبر
الاجيال شو السر في هذا الزيت
يعني هو يتم اختيار انواع معينه من
الزيتون في جبل الزيتون وهو جبل مطل على
البلده القديمه في القدس المحتله يتم
اختيار الزيتون ويعصر على مشارف مدينه بيت
لحم لقدسيه
هذه الارض بالنسبه للمسيحيين وبعدها يتم
الصلاه على هذا الزيت وخلطه بمجموعه من
الزيوت النباتيه زيت السمسم ماء الورد
القرفه ليصبح له رائحه طيبه ثم يحفظ في
زجاجه قديمه ويبعث الى قصر بيكنج هام لدهن
الملك وزوجه الملك ايضا تدهن من هذا الزيت
دلاله على قدسيه هذا الزيت في مباركه
الملك وفي مباراه مستقبله السياسي
حديث عن نفس الوصفه ذاتها الوصفه القديمه
التي استخدمت في تتويج الملكه اليزابيث
الثانيه وحتى اسلاف الملكه اليزابيث
يعني هو منذ اكثر من 1200 عام هذا
التقليد حاول
القائمون على الموضوع المحافظه على
تركيبته القديمه ولكن كسرت هذه القاعده
بعد مئات السنين
بعدم وضع عطور حيوانيه مثل
العنبر الذي يستخرج من الحيتان واستعاضه
عنه بزيوت نباتيه كما ذكرنا مثل زيت
السمسم ماء الورد
القرنفل القرفه وهذه النباتات هذا هو
التقليد الوحيد الذي اختلف عن التقليد
الاول وهو الذي انطلق عام 166
ما اهميه
هو لديه قدسيه لدى المسيحيين هي منطقه
مرتفعه تطل مباشره على البلده القديمه من
القدس المحتله من جبل الزيتون بامكانك
مشاهده
المسجد الاقصى كنيسه القيامه
هو منطقه مطله
مليء
الاثار المسيحيه ايضا لذلك لديه قدسيه
معينه وهو زيتون يسمى الزيتون الروماني
عمر هذا الزيتون الاف السنين لذلك يحمل
قدسيه خاصه لدى المسيحيين ويتباركون
بالزيت الذي يتم الصلاه عليه في كنيسه
القيامه في القدس
ومباركته ثم يرسل الى بريطانيا شكرا جزيلا
لك من رام الله مراسل صباح العربيه يا
خالد القاسم شكرا لك يا خالد